good evening
welcome to brooklyn college i am joseph
jovanelli the vice president for
administration and finance here at the
college
ms geller and professor aronoff excuse
me are joining us tonight
at the invitation of professor david
seiderman of the college
i am sure there will be an interesting
speech and that there will be a spirited
discussion following the presentation
colleges and universities play an
important role in our society
they offer free access to ideas places
where people may hear
and consider differing points of view
brooklyn college has a strong commitment
to the open exchange of ideas
we ask that each of you be respectful to
each other
and respectful of everyone's rights to
express their opinion
and that excuse me that you not
interrupt and please do not speak out of
order
there will be ample time allowed for
questions during a question and answer
period following the speaker's remarks
please follow the instructions of the
moderator during the question and answer
period
be aware that anyone engaging in
disorderly conduct
or disruptive behavior will be first
warned
and then asked to leave the room
the university may seek disciplinary or
criminal sanctions against persons who
engage in conduct
that violates university rules or state
or new york city laws lastly
please take a moment now to silence your
cell phones and other devices
thank you very much professor
good evening and thanks for coming uh
despite the somewhat inclement weather
thanks to professor seidman
for organizing the program and to
brooklyn college for hosting
our topic as you know is the first
amendment and social criticism
a crucial topic for a free society
freedom of speech is a global issue
various countries
have different standards some with
minimal restraints on freedom of speech
others where speaking your mind can cost
you your liberty your health
and even your life i'd like to read the
first amendment
to set the context of tonight's talk and
mention a few
uh well-known cases or incidents uh that
have been before the american courts
with regard to freedom of speech
so the first amendment freedom of speech
press
religion and petition congress shall
make no law
respecting an establishment of religion
or prohibiting the free exercise thereof
or abridging the freedom of speech or of
the press
or the right of the people peaceably to
assemble
and to petition the government for a
redress of
grievances american courts have ruled
that publicly burning an american flag
is a legally protected form
of freedom of expression protected by
the first amendment
the american nazi party planned to march
in skokie illinois
which then had a large number of jewish
holocaust survivors living there
the nazis held a march in chicago
swastikas on display
another case of first amendment rights
art that offends became an issue during
the giuliani administration
when a picture of the virgin mary which
incorporated elephant dung
was exhibited at the brooklyn museum
there were heated protests but then
outcries arose
for protecting freedom of expression
through art
protests were raised by those who felt
the opera about the murder of leon
klinghoffer was anti-semitic
but the show went on at the metropolitan
opera last year
freedom of speech
freedom of expression in academia as
vice president chavinelli mentioned
is a hot and constantly contested issue
on campus
and off professor andrew pessin at
connecticut college is now being
strongly criticized for a phrase that
appeared on his facebook page
columbia university invited then iranian
president ahmadinejad to speak despite
strong protests in his introduction that
evening
colombia president bollinger criticized
ahmadinejad
as a petty cruel dictator a holocaust
denier
and he criticized the iranian government
for killing children
but ahmadinejad had his freedom of
speech
israeli ambassador oren was shouted down
at the university of california at
irvine
however after the disrupters were
apprehended and after several
intermissions and a 20-minute break
he was able to speak his peace
and and on and on can a sponsor of a
parade exclude a group that the sponsor
feels
undermines the message or the mood of
the parade the courts have ruled
yes a very hot
issue of freedom of speech is with
regard to corporations and labor unions
and wealthy individuals
do they have the right to use their
money to advocate on political issues
the courts have ruled
yes can anti-war protesters
demonstrate at a soldier's funeral
despite the emotional trauma to the
family of the soldier
the courts have ruled yes outside of the
united states
controversy and violence have often
surrounded the issue of freedom of
speech
theo van gogh was murdered because of
his film about women and islam
journalists in russia have been murdered
in unsolved crimes labor union
organizers
are terrorized in many countries the
danish cartoonist who drew cartoons of
muhammad
was threatened and attacked but saved by
the secure
armored room in his house none of us
has forgotten the murder of the charlie
hebdo cartoonists and staff
or of the jews in the kosher grocery
store
all of which was followed by a moving
mass demonstration in the streets of
paris
advocacy for gay rights is a punishable
crime
in some countries salman rushdie lived
underground because of threats to his
life when satanic verses were published
in short defending freedom of speech is
an american
and a global issue where democracy
and human lives are at stake we're
fortunate to have the opportunity
tonight to hear from someone
outside of cuny i've yielded my time to
her
and so i will turn the program after
over to pamela geller after a brief
introduction
pamela geller is a noted figure in the
arena of freedom of speech and human
rights
she has declared that speech that is
offensive to some
must not be curtailed but must be
protected
in a genuinely free and pluralistic
society
ms geller is the founder editor and
publisher of atlas shrugs
she has been published in numerous
newspapers and periodicals
she has led awareness campaigns on
behalf of victims of honor killings
and in 2013 she was awarded the guardian
of freedom award
by the nassau county federation of
republican women
i